друзі Я хочу звернути вашу увагу що
відбувається в нас сьогодні найбільший
вплив в державі має низка людей яких
звуть радники офісу президента радники
президента цих людей як виявляється
якась неймовірна кількість в одного
Єрмака 58 різноманінітних помічників сім
заступників 13 радників ще 10 радників
ще порадників ще голова секретаріату
Тобто їх це десятки людей ці люди
безпосередньо впливають і контролюють
всі питання в нашій державі це люди є
головними в нашій державі бо наша
держава давно перетворилася в офіса
президентськуго замість
парламентсько-президентської і тому ці
люди мають себе декларувати мають бути
пепами за ними треба слідкувати за
їхніми руками бо на цих руках вже
наліпло стільки державних грошей майна і
Всього іншого що Це неймовірно але цих
людей в законі немає ще раз
Немає Знаєте цей закон можна назвати так
руки геть від друзів Єрмака оце буде
чесна назва цього закону і щоби про них
ніхто і надалі нічого не знав скільки
вони заробили що вони набрали що вони
накрали що в них є це і далі хочуть
залишити таємницю а це вчас знаєте от
Мені здається Ну ти от Єрмак от Єрмак в
тебе стільки є можливостей повноважень
всього То може ти хоча б зорганізуєш
роботу офісу президента ну на тебе там
тільки 58 радників порадників Працює Так
Може хоч це Друзі а тепер про роботи
офіса президента на одному дуже
показовому прикладі це стосується наших
військових про яких ми тут завжди
військові слава героям та мінімальну
повагу проявіть ми з вами 30 червня
прийняли закон закон України який
передбачає доп Ні ми прийняли його
Навіть раніше а 30 червня він вступив
вже в силу з підписом президента все як
треба доплати строковикам курсантам
обмежено придатним по захисту
батьківщини виведеним поза штат
інструкторам що ви думаєте на цю хвилину
в Збройних силах України хоч хтось з них
цю доплату отримав
ні ніхто ніхто цієї доплати До сих пір в
ЗСУ не отримав так в Нацгвардії вже
Слава Богу отримали в ДПС отримали а там
ніхто не отримав
ще раз четвертий місяць іде працює діє
закон не можуть банальну бюрократичну
роботу зробити і виплатити людям кошти
тим хто нас захищає ще в цьому законі
було дати можливість строковикам
перевестися в
мобілізовані ну Здавалося б Ну нам
говорять нам потрібні люди на фронт Ну
так будь ласка добровільне право тисячі
строковиків на це чекають щоб дати
можливість молодим людям здоровим
навченим
вже Взяти їх в мобілізовані дати
можливість виконувати бойові завдання
люди хочуть державі це потрібно закон ми
з вами нарешті прийняли
тепер Це проста річ офіс президента мав
підготувати зміни в Указ Президента про
порядок проходження військової служби
четвертий місяць вони не в змозі цього
зробити четвертий місяць чим займається
ірмак чим займаються ці 58 порадників
вони знущаються з нас елементарну
найпростішу роботу в світі вони виконати
не можуть Я вимагаю щоб негай це було
зроблено щоб розблокований був цей закон
а оцих цих радників порадників треба
взяти і дати їм копняка і першому єрмаку
от цей закон має бути
копнякаєрмаку за те як він організував